Where are you living right now?
I'm close to chilliwack in British
Columbia.
Are there speed dating,
speed dating all available there?
I don't know if there's services like
that,
but I know a lot of people are using
apps on your phone like tinder.
One of the things I like about speed
dating,
like at least once is because it gives
you a chance to talk to a very large
number of women very rapidly.
Well,
first of all,
that's a good way of it's exposure,
right?
It's a good way of overcoming that fear
of initial contact,
but I think it also introduces you in a
very blunt way to the diversity of
personality,
right?
Because what you'll find if you go on a
speed dating,
uh,
what retreat,
um,
is that there'll be nothing between you
and the girl.
In many cases there'll be something,
there are sometimes,
sometimes that's okay.
You know,
you don't have to be attracted,
attracted to or attracted to anyone.
Everyone forcing exposure to that wide
variety of experience in a short period
of time can be a good way of overcoming
your fear.
And a lot of that's just an experience
that fear too,
right?
So you got to figure out how to overcome
that.
And then I would say with apps like
tinder,
it's trickier because the degree to
which sexual activity is implied in the
initial meeting,
you know,
in the initial agreement to hook up is
unclear,
but it might be worthwhile just to make
a rule for yourself,
which is that,
you know,
you'll go on 25 tinder dates but you
won't engage in any physical contact
because it'll get you,
it'll,
it'll solve that problem for you,
you know what I mean?
And then you can concentrate on the
conversation and you can concentrate on,
on overcoming this inexperienced that
you have,
that's,
that's interfering with your progress
forward.
But that good a rule like that just
makes it simple.
No.
And you need rules like that.
And you know,
you probably know this,
but maybe you don't mean your experience
with regards to being avoidant and
afraid of contact with women is by no
means rare.
It's unbelievably common among young
men.
And I think it is exacerbated by the
factors that you just described,
which is that you were taught,
young men are taught in particular that
any show of even confidence on their
part might be interpreted as part of
this toxic masculinity.
And I think that,
well that's a,
that's something that would have to be
unpacked for hours.
I mean what I would say is that women
generally like men who have power but
don't need to use it.
It's something like that.
And women who are,
who are uncertain and unsettled in the
relationships with men would rather for
their own safety that all men be
rendered powerless.
But that's not helpful because it
destroys erotic attraction.
And then all that happens is that men,
dap useless.
So it's not a solution,
you know,
like to destroy someone's power is no
solution to taming them.
Right?
You want someone powerful but civilized,
not someone we so weak,
they can't do anything wrong.
And I think the message that young men
get a lot in our society is you should
be so weak that you can't do anything
wrong.
And that's a really bad message.
It doesn't do anyone any good.
Yeah,
I've,
I've been seeing that like it seems like
women are being told to be more
masculine and that if it's a negative
thing for women to be feminine and
negative for men to be masculine.
And even in,
in,
in Brampton where I was living,
I saw these posters around the mall
saying,
who says women can't be leaders?
What's,
what's wrong with throwing like a girl?
And because it was being pushed on me so
much,
I felt like I was just accepting it,
but now I've sort of seen through that.
But yeah,
I'm going to use it.
I think that's great advice that you
just gave a minute.
Yeah.
As well.
We also have to account for the stunning
popularity of 50 shades of gray.
You know,
there's all this surface talk about
about toxic masculinity and the,
you know,
the overbearing rape culture that's
characteristic of men and that the
attempt to,
um,
what would you say,
I suppose castrate would be the wrong
word,
but maybe I'll use it anyways.
But then there's this underground desire
that's manifest in the attraction of
that sort of literature.
I mean,
that was the fastest selling book in
human history and so there's really
something to be said about that and the
fact that those two things can coexist
at the same time,
in the same culture is an indication of
just how,
how much conversation there needs to be
about what the proper role of
masculinity and femininity as and also
how to organize sexual behavior so that
people are not pathologized by it.
You know,
it's so interesting to me to watch
what's happening on the campuses
because,
um,
and,
and that's emblematic of what happens in
the broader world.
I mean,
at the same time we have discussions
about how absolutely every form of
sexual desire and behavior whatsoever is
entirely permissible.
We have the increasing multiplication of
regulations about every single aspect of
any sexual interaction between a man and
a woman.
I mean those two things.
The fact that those two things are
happening at the same time means that
something is wrong.
I mean,
maybe we should back off on the idea
that absolutely every form of sexual
interaction whatsoever is permissible
and desirable and simultaneously back
off on the increasing enclosure of every
of every physical interaction in a web
of of laws and regulations,
most of which are going to be
counterproductive and caused all sorts
of trouble.